Oh what's going on you two good morning
and uh heavy [ __ ] on today's episode of
heart-to-heart with Jamie so we had the
famous Carla uh wasn't it
Clara Chung yeah and I know who she is
the interview process was great
we're gonna get to know a little bit
more about who she really is and I hope
y'all enjoy it so uh
come on car smells like hell here
okay so we're outside and we're getting
ready to interview Clara I need you get
focused
wait did you ask her if it's okay huh no
that's not important like we just we're
just gonna go out of here go home Isaac
hey come on oh hold on my friend you're
not going anywhere I don't think so
huh I'm not doing this you're not you're
not doing what let me tell you something
I gave you $5.00 and a pack of juicy
fruit you're doing this give it back
then get back don't stuff it mean the
potato sidharthak I'm ready hello
everybody and welcome to the famous
house Oh Carly Cheng College my name is
Claire who are you Holly Cup Claire Chun
Carly choice yeah who are you that that
doesn't matter what anyways uh are we at
the right house house you need to get
out anyways could you could talk to the
camera excuse me I don't be hey hey oh
this is not
yeah give me a hit I don't know about
this man
what don't you know about what this is
wrong what's wrong hey you never broke
into a house before idiot tell you
something else miss Claridge ha Carla
what's the name something else miss
clearly give me eight of you oh my god I
think you overreacted I think you broke
into my house so I'm not overreacting
and that's just weird
how was that weird I don't either way I
want an apology
okay I'm sorry I'll take that moat I
understand that sometimes your dad okay
you're not you'll put your hands on me
like that let me tell you something
nobody puts their hands on David so to
do this you know this interview
Wow gotcha
are you okay no I'm really so much
puppeteers all this wait I could sing
you a song no how do you wanna hear good
Oh pepper we'll see you later on tonight
I asked you to be my girlfriend right
like this month I'll be like hella cute
when he's this will look like he touched
himself in just passed up